muy buenas noches desde tokio pues esta
ceremonia se espera que sea bastante
sobria
pero que tendrá un tema muy importante y
es caminar juntos hacia adelante ese es
el tema de esta ceremonia seguir juntos
hacia adelante justamente después de un
año y medio de pandemia después de que
estos juegos pues tuvieran que ser
aplazados por más de 11 días 11 meses y
bueno pues ya acá está el gran día en
este estadio olímpico de toque un
beijing bellísima una bellísima sede de
estos juegos y bueno estará ahí ahí está
el emperador ha de naruhito o sea será
el encargado de abrir de declarar
abiertos estos juegos tal como lo hizo
su abuelo en 1964 los juegos aquí en
tokio solamente hay 950 invitados que
pudieron entrar hoy a este estadio para
ver esta ceremonia pues en la que se ha
visto envuelta en muchas polémicas
porque ya su director artístico pues se
fue relevado de su cargo el día de ayer
hace unos días uno de los compositores
también tuvo que
de renunciar entonces esto lo que de
todas maneras este es el momento
importante de estos juegos un momento
muy importante para japón